this movie come from many ideas about
how the people not so younger can face
the future and but also it's a movie
about the memories and the relationship
between the parents and the children and
and mostly it's a movie about a
conductor and a filmmaker yes now
Michael Paolo wrote this movie with you
in mind right you were the conductor in
his head when my agent said I've got a
script from Paolo Sorrentino for you I
didn't believe that because I didn't
think he was on I thought it wasn't I'd
seen all his movies you know and I just
seen great beauty and he'd won the Oscar
for best foreign movie and I thought he
was on a whole different plane from me
you know and he wouldn't have heard of
someone like me so she said she said oh
so he said you know he wrote it for you
and if you don't do it he won't do it
and I laughed because I thought it was a
joke
and it wasn't so I nearly said it I'll
do it I don't need to see the script
I'll just do it but I said send me the
script there's a little bit of
professionalism she snuck in but I was
so overwhelmed by the whole thing
and then when I read the script of
course and I don't see what did it do it
I would have done it for nothing but I
didn't tell them that but I'd love doing
it and I love I love Paola and also
loved the rest of this cast who I think
are absolutely brilliant
now Rachel I think under the best of
circumstances the scene the scene right
when you're covered in mud and you're
giving your amazing monologue would be
very difficult to do but then I was
reading about how even more difficult it
was considering the circumstances of
when you filmed it it's a beautifully
written monologue and it was my first
night of filming it was my first day
which was a night shoot and it was 3
a.m. and we got covered in mud and then
Paolo just said oh we're gonna do it in
one take which was a new piece of
information which is how Paolo works I
think with everyone in that there's no
rehearsal there's no discussion you just
do it but to be told that a three-page
monologue will be in one take rather
than 25 setups or whatever is is bold
but it's that feeling that you just have
to jump into the deep end with him you
learn your line so I did my homework I'd
loved my lines and then it was just time
to time time to do it so he just he just
pushes you into into his uh his big poem
of a swimming pool you just get you just
get pushed in yeah your character was a
character from the days in the studio
system when you're under contract as a
movie star now did you take specific
inspiration from specific actresses not
consciously but I grew up knowing
Barbara Stanwyck and Betty Davis and
because they were friends of my father's
and you know I I knew some of those
divas in those studio days and so I
think that's kind of in my DNA I think
maybe Stanwyck the most but you know it
wasn't conscious it's just Paulo knows
exactly what he wants and he tells you
what to do and you do it now David how
did you go about writing a simple song
number three I mean this is the song
that means so much and has characterized
this man's career for his life and has
you know been both kind of the thing
that hangs over him and the thing that
defines him in a way that's a lot of
pressure for one song to do
those things how did you create it well
the interesting thing for me was that
because music plays such a large role in
the movie
everybody's music not just Fred
ballinger
music but music is so important in the
movie I had to write the song before the
script was really finished you know
because it was shot on screen so a lot
of this was working with a script
talking to Paulo trying to figure out
who this character was what his journey
was and I sort of realized from reading
the script that the song had to contain
kind of both ends of his journey it had
to be where he began when he wrote it
when he was young and full of optimism
and love and youth and where he is at
the end where he's looking at the end
and his wife is no longer able to be the
same person she was to him at the
beginning so it had to be something that
that carried you know kind of the entire
emotional weight of that journey that
the character makes so for me the
process was reading the script thinking
about it thinking about my own life
getting you know hugely depressed and
miserable making versions of the song
sending them to Paulo and Paulo sending
them back and saying oh it's very nice
but you know can't you be more emotional
so so basically you know Paulo
challenged me to push it as far as I
could push it so I and I really
appreciated that was it very difficult
to find the location and and how did you
come about all that I have to say that I
try to push Paul to go to north of Italy
to show this but and it did locate a
scouting they're not founding a not
funding what the it wasn't was looking
for and so it was here in Los Angeles
when when we even found some photographs
of these hotels in because our two
different health in in Switzerland in
Davos and enflames and said yes this is
where I want to shoot so we went there
and I try to arrange a co-production
with Switzerland and I did attend so it
worked
but that location played such an
important part in the film how did it
affect your performances was it
something that was really that affected
you in a way when you were don't do this
all right because it was holiday it was
out of season and there was no staff in
the hotel there was no room service
there was no laundry or nothing like
that
we were now bought kettles and toasters
to get snacks and there was a hamburger
place at the bottom of the hill and and
there was a pizza place
so you know we just kept walking up and
down hills with the hamburgers and the
pizzas and we never gained any weight so
it was fine it's all part of the plan
did part of the plan yes Pete sir
hamburger Jane which one did you prefer
for me it was like I it was just so
bizarre being in this place that was
empty and then these endless tunnels
because it's primarily a ski resort in
the wintertime and now it's summer so
there all of these long white
underground tunnels that all look alike
I mean I don't know about you all I got
lost so many times can you imagine
months later they find Jane Fonda to
seeing this tunnel in water I mean the
gym wasn't even open and all those
places that they shoot all these great
scenes then wasn't open and then you
know I was wandering around this
incredible place finding thinking where
is he gonna shoot this very intimate
scene with with me and Harvey you know
it's just two people talking and I
figured maybe in the little library or
something then I found out it was gonna
be in the ballroom which was like
outside in these two little chairs at
one end and a ping-pong table and the
what does that mean now the ping-pong
table was there when I did the scouting
location and I said okay I wouldn't I
don't love that the people work too much
you can you can live it can stay here
now Jane how do you approach a part like
that where it's few scenes but very
memorable scenes do you approach a part
like that differently than you would
when if you're on screen every scene I
think so I've never done this I never
did such a short amount of time in a
film and it's really fun to be you know
do it and be done with it and then hang
around and watch him work with all these
people but no I mean we did it
differently Harvey we we did it one way
from beginning to end and then he said
now do it with no anger and as we did
that and now do it really really angry
and we did that I mean he had us too he
was conducting now Harvey this is the
first time you and Michael have worked
together and how is it forming you know
you have to form on screen this 30-year
40-year relationship did you have time
to rehearse Paolo doesn't like to
rehearse did you have time together
before you started those themes that
Paulo wrote about we're very deep in
very far-reaching and nothing in those
themes was foreign to me and I suppose
not for Michael either and then we had
this bond we like to laugh about that
Michael was in the British Army I was in
the American marines so he had a
language of our own that was sort of
x-rated Michael I found Michael and
incredibly easy I've got a dad so I
didn't have to research that I have a
dad who I have very strong feelings for
who's not a composer but he's successful
in his own right and lovable and
impossible and equal measure but we
Michael's a very very easy person to
form for me we just formed a real heart
connection really really quickly it
wasn't hard work or a struggle and we
just even on that spar scene where we
first met covered in mud you know in
between takes we make each other laugh
and Michael tell me look Michaels had an
extraordinary life he's met so
people he's worked with so many people
he's one of the great rock on tires he's
just listening to him tell stories I
could just just be near him always and
listen to his story so it was it was
just a pleasure for me he's easy to love
so easy to love I also have two
daughters you see so I know exactly how
to deal with the daughter in a movie
what you do is say don't ever go out
with him again that's the main line for
a father with daughters